à la limite par qui c'est vous ferez
plaisir d'être traité de cons
et de tolérance on va faire une
interview à la limite
à la limite pierre Lelouch pour quel
homme politique de gauche pourriez-vous
voter
Dominique Strauss-Kahn
à la limite avec quelle idée du Parti
communiste et de vous d'accord
de défendre la tradition française de la
chasse contre les écolos
ça c'est dommage mais il faut que je
t'emmène à la chasse au cas aux
électeurs
aimeriez-vous que Nicolas Sarkozy ne
soit pas président de la République
seule raison que je vois c'est qu'il
soit heureux en ne l'étant pas
à la limite par qui c'est vous ferez
plaisir d'être traité de cons
Bernard Debré ah oui d'accord
Jean-Louis Debré
vous coucher aucun aucun même à la
limite même vous je pourrais
même vous mais non mais arrêtez tout
tendu tu es tout cyanosé relaxe-toi
c'est samedi soir écoute je vais te dire
je sais bien qu'à Paris
mais je vais pas y arriver je suis trop
branché bonne femme c'est une réalité à
la limite pour quoi diriez-vous merci à
François Mitterrand
pour l'alternance parce que je crois que
c'est ça dans une société
la peine de mort aussi pour la peine de
la rétabli
à la limite quel homme politique de
droite décrédibilise la droite
Michael a répondu parce qu'il a
fondamentalement il ira de socle
à la limite quelle est la mesure de
Bertrand Delanoë que vous approuvez
j'approuve j'approuve pari plage
j'approuve les nuits blanches
certainement le sens de la fête
certainement
point
à la limite pour quelle raison on
aimeriez-vous pas être maire de Paris
pour avoir une vie normale et pour être
sûr de ne rien rater de innarditude
abonnez-vous et mettez un pouce bleu